I have one question and one question
only what is your favorite block in
Minecraft what what is your favorite
minecraft
[Music]
that's right everybody cringe Tuesday's
is here and it's here to stir you today
we're focusing on Minecon minecraft kids
are still cringing
I get it alright first of all full
disclaimer all kids are cringing
I've been creamed gee I'm 30 and I am
still cringy but that doesn't mean I can
still laugh at kids goddamnit that is
not that is not gonna stop me from
laughing and socially inept children
okay I genuinely love these clips they
bring me joy and I want to experience
them even though I probably haven't seen
all of them multiple times awkward
moments at Minecon 2015 okay one more
let's go for it I love this yes the
patient's dipped in gold well how do you
respond to something like that you're
standing on stage they can't ask you
there one more let's go for it what do
you do a spell on dance that's what's
really happening here it's cute it's
cute alright it's not your inch if it's
cute wait the point is to be cringe well
whatever how much money do you have
[Laughter]
bill how God um how many of you have
autism and if so has it helped you in
your modding career
personal think about we're going to
refuse that question I think I'm afraid
we have to pass on that one sorry
well done well well good job
de-escalating a silly question from a
child good job is it really that hard
Jesus Christ showing this left side um I
was wondering um what's the what
commended amount of detonated wham I
should have to serve what is super kind
doing today that's all I want to know
what is super kind doing I just love how
it seems like he shocked himself with
the question after he asks it
how much dedicated Wham dated wham I
should have deserve dedicated to wham to
a server dedicated Wham
is it that hard to understand sir France
really holds you hostage and room 208
yesterday what would you like to join my
Mike my dad's minecraft minecraft'
shovel mine Forge crap I've got business
cards here join you join his mica [ __ ]
oh I'll join I'll gladly join I'm having
a hard time here what to say but they go
I'll just say yes and move on my god
please I feel like you are doing equally
bad job here why do you do what you do
like why do you do these mod packs for
thousands of people to watch like
what's your purpose in doing huh it's
good just friggin philosophy into my
conch what is the purpose of what you do
what is it what is the meaning behind it
what is the purpose behind these
minecraft pakka mines
oh god it's beautiful I haven't seen I
haven't had the stomach to sit through
one of these before
Oh what do you have to like further
improve the mods like I'm sorry like
what are you doing to further improve
the mobs how we program them like what
what do you movements or anything are
being added into the game oh my god oh
my god ah I really this is the kids are
not the problem the kids are just being
kids
it's the panelists oh my god what are
you doing to help increase it watch it
we're gonna make them faster we're gonna
make them stronger and we're gonna make
them look better Jesus Christ just say
anything do it instead of no what do I
do to fix my math I was using red power
cream man they're gonna dropping I was
[Laughter]
straight sweet strength this is flowing
through my body bit crank just sir just
through my blood veins and vessel and I
feel more powerful and we get the same
time
oh excuse me for interrupting this video
Nord VPN let me tell you all about it
you're browsing internet unprotected you
don't have a VPN even though article 13
pass and it's a worldwide issue that you
need to somehow get by through with or
don't worry I'm here to help with a VPN
you can appear like you're browsing
anywhere on the Internet if business
Anya is blocked in India don't worry
baby just download an orde VPN just
check out Nord VPN comm / PewDiePie and
you'll get 75% off that's a great price
$2.99 for 30 sec c'mon ain't you get an
extra month if you use PewDiePie you're
welcome
VPN helps you browse safely on the
Internet if you're traveling using
public Wi-Fi your risk easily getting
hacked or Deckard but no VPN will solve
that problem
owls on a personal level and really glad
that there are actually programs now
that the world seems to become more and
more restricted by dummy dumb rules that
are dummy dumb easy way to get past it
use a VPN I highly recommend it I use it
as well
you can also use it on your phone it's
nice simple easy and smooth just like
mine check out link description
you're welcome broski's keep watching
video now where did the name sky
vachetta Russ and I asked up quick come
from cuz I know Jordan and we need to
realize mid-sentence now you don't
really give it about the question I
already get the question dammit
oh yeah you go buddy question can you
sign this me all of you that's your
question that's a comic I can relate to
this so much it was the same when we did
our panel and very wise I that's not a
question
I'll be technically yes but no Tarpley
thing will happen with the community
when minecraft will die well it's going
to be over
plot twist minecraft never dies he knew
all the long you have something like
plans on how to stop sort of like
corporate creep getting into my young
[Laughter]
age so beautifully as a parent I really
appreciate you using all the appropriate
language in your videos and
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm a big fan take that compliment look
he's he's a saint
my name is Dante I've actually written a
parody song and I'm wondering if you
could look at it so as far as the the
parody stuff might I tend to try keeping
it all the lyrics to me writing them and
then sort of bouncing them off of each
wearing David if you contact me via
Twitter or something I can I can do my
best to get back to you on that
you are
[Applause]
thank you Hey hi wait
this is gonna look weird but you can't
hit hello why is it so good so good I
love it so much it makes me happy
I don't get it Jesus Christ Oh God
they're clearly in the costume for a
reason hi there's a bit of a rivalry
between me and my friends back at home
about whether cows or pigs are better
and I was wondering are there going to
be any cow pets in the game at any point
are you the are you the cow guy yeah
now today is my birthday it's not I'm
not gonna ask you you see me happy
birthday but everyone spam cap in the
chat and let's get a nice loud kappa
yeah no yes let's try again
[Music]
this is cringy this is cringy I'm sorry
cringe compliation hi I have no idea
yeah I have a feeling it's gonna be a
long hour guy looks so out of place
hello hello I want to design games and
stuff and a friend of mine said if I
give him 750 pounds you've put this game
it'll make her happen for me but it's
gotta be cash which I support being sort
of follow me in your youtubes yeah well
best of luck yeah hope it goes good for
you man
well
which you follow me with it though with
YouTube's yeah of course if you've got
you boy you got I've got your word on
that
yes sir I will you be my friend I like
to think we're already friends yeah I
Got News for you we're already friends
yeah thanks guys you thinking we've
created that doesn't kill you makes you
stronger I like to think so at least I
like to think that you're suffering for
a reason my friend wants 750 dollars in
cash it has to be cash and he's gonna
make a game will you guys follow me on
the YouTube oh god damn it
what happened through the game people
don't know but this is actually how
tuber simulated it was funded bollocks
question and this is the last one the
pressure how many kids have you
entertained fine what what is your fave
no kid minecraft favorite oh god how can
I pick one I get it it can't be easy I'm
not trying to pretend like I'm better
I'm sure if I was there it would be I
would I would want her to present being
in this compilations okay whether I was
a youtuber or an audience audience
member audience member Jesus crying okay
one more let's go for it oh are you
making tea okay if I'm a tea
[Applause]
it's not you females don't very often
refer to themselves as gamers so you
don't realize how many females are
gamers because it's more of a guy thing
to label themselves whereas girls are
just like get something I do
anyone can be a game even if it's like
doing a Sudoku on your phone it was
actually not a bad answer and then she
just had to jump in with that line to
just ruin a man I'm not hating I have to
do Chrome iPhone guess I'm a gamer
that's right
guess I'm a gamer after all huh oh you
two make some noise if you have a
youtube channel all right this is as
much as I can stomach that was beautiful
I feel fantastic smash like subscribe
and goodbye